all right thank you guys for coming to
our talk I know it's after lunch and no
one wants to be here but
but no uh so we're gonna be talking
about hopefully something that interests
everyone this is modern upgrade screens
and considerations for updating
production models
um before we get into the presentation
let me introduce myself and Emmanuel I'm
a machine learning engineer at 33 uh I
was a Rex research scientist at NYU with
lots of my research focusing on automl
as well as data provenance and then by
trade I'm an electrical engineer Manuel
also machine learning engineer he's
going to be taking the second half of
his talk uh he has a PHD in
computational science as well as his
postdoc research was in computational
biophysics and genomics
finally a bit about the company because
not many people know what Munich does
essentially States into the business is
where we are B2B companies so we work
with lots of insurance carriers
throughout the us and we try to
semi-automate their underwriting or data
processing needs
um it also means that because we're
working with lots of financial data lots
of health data we have we work under
this interesting interest
uh regulations whether it be data
regulations for their opportunity
or CCPA if it's California or
um every state has its own really high
level of recognitions for insurance
providers that we have to look at all
those regulations as well and then of
course anything that has to do with
Health Data and like involves pii which
is personally personally if you
personally identifiable information you
have to also regulate
so uh that's a bit about the the company
about us but uh that's not what the talk
is about uh we are going to be talking
about how to update your models in
production and uh this is how we're
gonna be structured uh we're gonna I'm
gonna pose a problem at the start where
we had like a model a production use
case a prototype essentially that made
it to production and sort of how we sort
of developed it into a full-scale
production Pipeline with continuous
training in there with monitoring in
there and how we use the four C's of ml
apps to get there
uh then there will be some uh I'm going
to walk you through our exact process
with the construction Pipeline and some
of the considerations that we had along
the way there's like lots of general
advice in there of course and again
these are very very use case specific
and we use case somewhat various but uh
these were really helpful
for us
it's like a recipe
and then finally uh we're going to be
talking about model validation and
that's when Emmanuel's gonna I'm gonna
tag him in and he's gonna be talking
about the statistical comparisons we did
uh when you're comparing to classifiers
so think of it as like a model called
the CM where two models come in and one
leaves whichever is better and then he's
going to talk about all the frequent
tests we did and the Bayesian strategies
and how you can decide that on the slide
and then finally it's going to end it
with other considerations for uh for us
as an industry in the industry as an
insurance provider but apart from that
um other consideration that might be
useful for people generally thinking
about demonstrating my friends
um
yeah so let's let's go over where it all
started so this is uh this is one of our
products one of our carriers wanted us
to semi hypotenate their needs they're
like hey we have all this policy
information can you somehow automate the
underwriting which is like this
classification of these policies and
you're like uh the first stage of that
would be
do you are these even eligible to be
automated and that's like
um do you do a bunch of business you
have like a list of different
requirements like let's say if a person
a policy person has a specific disease
cancer or something you can't really
automate that you have to have a person
uh look at that policy uh in more detail
so you can't really automate those and
so they're like but if you can automate
those if they follow a specific uh
criteria then how do you assess risk
class for it and this essentially is uh
what we what we what our data scientists
build where there was Data Warehouse
with all these policies and parsing
pipelines which would take into their
warehouse data then uh some
pre-processing work converting it into
more schemas uh some edas and kickouts
so kick out to our business use case
um filters and um CDA is exploratory
data analysis then feature generation
model training evaluation a pretty
traditional data science problem here
every data scientist knows what what how
to train a model and this is what the
pipeline looks like but once you have
this data science strategy set up you
don't really know how to
how to serve it in production and that's
where we uh that's because this is a
prototype the easiest solution back then
was take the model take a little pickle
convert into a pickle file and sort of
push it into a registry and then from
that registry ingest it into a
prediction service followed by an app
which will be interfacing with uh with
with your client and this is what you
also call an ml Ops level zero
deployment because it's it's very well
defined in experimentation but when
you're talking about production it's
it's kind of wonky you don't really want
to have something like this when you're
serving a big client and so uh but it
doesn't mean that this is a bad solution
MLA level zero deployment which metallic
majority deployments are very good when
you're prototyping and of course feed to
Market but uh but we wanted to scale it
up and the way we did that was we used
the four C's of mlops
um it is integration delivery monitoring
and training
we borrowed the CI CD from our brothers
into software engineering from devops
and what they stand for is continuously
testing your code when it's in
production when it's when it's uh when
it's being rolled out just so you have
the best quality of your code bases uh
which is very highly reliable it's
actually and then continuous delivery
would be taking all of this stuff and
package it and then pushing it uh to a
place without a middle person involved a
humans shouldn't really involve this too
so packaging your code packaging your
reliable code and these CI CD in
software engineering really help you
develop pipelines which are reliable
they should help shorten delivery Cycles
they have like their own benefits but
we've talked about when it but when we
talk about ml systems we have to also
incorporate continuous monitoring and
training into the equation and
continuous monitoring would help you
drill down into the performance of your
model you should be you should have good
insight into what's happening with the
data with the model everything that's
that's what surrounds the model the
whole Pipeline and that's what contest
monitoring is about and once you have
identified a problem then you should
have a training strategy for example if
you need a training strategy and use the
training pipeline to sort of update your
models uh this is what we uh sort of
started that we wanted to have a CI CDC
MCT situation set up in our ml level 0
deployment uh and so this is how we
essentially did it
um so actually just before I get into
the process there's like this one part
of uh the the pipeline that I did not
mention so far so this is what it looked
like in production there was a user
talking to the topicia app which was
interfacing with the production
the prediction service is talking to a
production database which will be
storing everything that comes into your
prediction service let's say a policy
comes in it would be stored into the
production database along with whatever
it was
um whatever the prediction was
and we track all of these and there's
like a hidden feedback loop in the
background because we want to monitor
the performance of these models and a
feedback loop essentially uh requires us
to take some data out and manually label
it as our industry has like we can't
really automate this process it has to
go through a person so what we do is we
take a segment of the production data
randomly a random holdout said which
would be labeled by subject matter
experts these experts would then
um these experts would label this data
return it to us and we would have we'd
use this as a proxy for model
performance so say uh
um and essentially use this model
performance to monitor how fresh the
model is how it's getting stale or not
and then what's really cool about this
part is that you can actually use the
data that the the return to retrainer
model essentially and make our models
fresh
but that's what the the feedback looks
like looks like but essentially when we
started this the first part was
identifying if problems come up and we
had to sort of sum up uh incorporate a
monitoring service so let me introduce
to you in this diagram Emily the mle
and that's my only tokens presentation
but Emily the mle has now is talking to
can now talk to a Monitoring Service uh
the learning service has a good Insight
on what's happening on the production
database uh what's really important for
Emily to do at this point is talk to all
the different stakeholders business
counterparts talk to uh software
Engineers devops everyone who wants to
monitor stuff to uh to sort of have this
as part of of the monitoring service so
there's like one uh box in to see
everything that's happening in the in
the pipelines and in the production data
um a good monitoring service of course
has business kpis in there for us it
would have been like the number of
automated cases per week it could have
been uh if there are some specific
reason codes so when we sort of use
policies uh we have to when we sort of
risk we produce risk classes we also
have to give a reason essentially of why
that risk was uh classified as this risk
and not a better one or a worse one and
that's just like one of the regulations
on us so um so let's say if there's a
more uh four prevalent reason quote than
the other we have to all suspected by
that and so that was that could have
been one of the key business apis for
performance it could have been uh it was
something more towards software
engineers and devops requirements so
let's say traces and all the other uh is
is my model performing uh in the
expected time frame that is supposed to
require return a response and how what
do the traces look like and other
business software engineering metrics
the data metrics would be more geared
towards what the data looks like so you
would want to see what the distribution
of the predictions are like or let's say
uh
what does uh the correlation between
different features look like so having
all those metrics in mind uh you come up
with like a list of code bench metrics
and the next stage next step is
identifying acceptable thresholds
because to be able to pinpoint problems
you need to have thresholds and uh once
you have those thresholds you can sort
of be a little more confident about
what's happening in the uh
the next stage once you have a
monitoring service set up and we know
what's happening inside data is to
sort of talk about triggers
and triggers are essentially
um
the triggers are essentially your way to
once you have the problems identified
you want to be able to trigger a retrain
if it's necessary and uh the return
should be uh it could depend on your
performance on the model performance of
course uh give me one sec because I got
lost because this timer says I'm in 25
minutes but I don't think I'm 25 minutes
all right cool so yeah so going back to
the monitoring service like once you
have the monitoring service set up you
need to have code triggers and a
complete solution
would be able to re-trigger a continuous
training run under any of the following
circumstances it would be able
to weather
uh new data comes in or performance
degradation is monitored by the
monitoring service periodically which
was one of our use cases because we
could we our label data would come in in
intervals and you could
essentially quantities and then uh upon
stakeholders requests of course because
data scientists love to have fresh
models but once it also remember at this
point that there can be false alarms uh
you shouldn't always rely on uh you
should you should rely on the market
service of course but you should have a
deeper understanding on what's happening
in the model as well
as well uh because there could be
something wrong with the data set there
could be something wrong
but in the code that actually is getting
you to the getting you the data to that
point uh it could be it could be
something that should be wrong with the
pre-processing you should be very very
comfortable and this is this goes back
to having like code fleshed out CI CD
pipelines where you would be able to be
able to identify these bugs before they
happen
um so yeah once you have the trigger set
up you are confident in what's going to
trigger these runs uh it's it's devising
a data selection strategy
now remember the goal of this entire CT
pipeline is to have highly relevant
models performing optimally but I want
to remember that
recency does not necessarily equate to
relevancy it's possible that the newest
data essentially isn't represented of
what the model is to do unexpected to do
so one should have that in mind before
deciding which approach to use there's a
naive approach where you could just use
the newest data set and train your model
against it
or you could use like moving Windows
where you start
looking at uh let's say the past five
weeks of data and back test it
essentially a history model or you could
also have Dynamic Windows there if
you're let's say the window size is
is a hyper parameter of your model
training run so you could retrain a
model and like window size and you
optimize essentially on the windows
but
um and that's that's one of the
strategies I think we used I think for
us was using new data and old data we
still didn't combine them that worked
very well also because like our model
lifespans are so huge drift comes in
gradually and so we can get away with a
lot of things that like let's say a
recommendation system for uh shopping
recommendations
so um I guess the next step is one yeah
I should also mention that uh a delayed
delayed feedback uh do can means that it
can mean that the labels are no longer
valid hours was three months to three
months if they're getting labeled it
every once that's fine but again going
back to a shopping recommendation system
here feedback
and then finally enforcing extensive
data validation checks is very very
important at this stage as well remember
that we do not want to ingest bad data
into especially an automated pipeline
that's that's not that's not good I
would recommend using feature stores
because you could monitor what the
quality of your data in feature stores
you could have transforms in there and
everything data is ingested you can have
validate
validate what you're expecting as
using feature stories is very very
helpful
okay so uh
we have data what do we do next
um I think the next stage is deciding
the extent of the retrain that's
required now uh when you started we
wanted to train a model uh on the latest
data or like a subset of latest data on
depending on whatever our data selection
strategy was but let's say there's a use
case where the business needs changed
essentially and that necessarily
translates into a modern upgrade
situation because things training
pipelines are great if you have a
feedback loop which doesn't really
require you to let's say change the
model in any way you just use the latest
data and refit the exact same model with
uh with with that data information but
if you've had to change your model
that's the business needs changed or
let's say your feature engineering
change or something like that you should
probably take this back into
experimentation and start with the
experimentation part and have
experimentation decide what the best
model is then push it to production and
then have that as part of it
so updates and upgrades are kind of
different there up to the update if
you're updating your model that's ideal
continuous training pipelines should
identically be uh should ideally be
identical to their experimentation
counterparts
uh also one very important thing is to
maintain retrain run metadata remember
that anything fails if you need to have
a fallback option and we should be able
to go back to whatever uh our starting
uh our previous run essentially
okay uh you have a new model now and
with the new model what we want to do is
test if this is a better model
the first thing to ask is what even does
better mean
right it's it's essentially it's what
the business decides if you're talking
about let's say uh other considerations
if there's fairness considerations bias
considerations in your data that you
have trouble what a better model
essentially is and then also like does
it solve like the use case in a better
way or like is this updated model
actually
um producing better predictions or is it
producing let's say
the same amount of predictions before
the degradation started happening
I think another way one way to test
model validation or people how people
values their models is there's two ways
essentially there's an online version
and an offline version in the industry
people talk about Canary deployments or
pilgrain deployments which are going to
go really fancy you can talk about
multi-armed planted deployments where
you're actually having these models this
in production there's offline strategies
which apply more to us uh where you have
let's say you can do predictive quality
assessment where you assess the quality
model right similarly to how you did it
in your experimentation is just how you
evaluated you use the evaluation there
then you can also talk about comparing
performance across certain classes or
against different Baseline models or you
could essentially have more statistical
techniques that push that decide whether
this model is better or not and so for
us for example uh we wanted to go much
deeper into how what a better model is
versus another and that's what we
actually wanted to spend more time on
because each of these different parts
could be its own talk but model
validation was something that's pretty
dear and here to us and so we have I'm
going to switch the conversation up a
bit and I'm going to have Emmanuel take
over who's going to be talking about our
validation strategy about the
frequencies and the patient tests that
we did and then how we come up with a
better model
and then he's going to finish with the
other considerations that he
has so I'm going to give it to Emmanuel
and thank you I'll see you in a minute
hi
thanks man enough
um I am going to talk about
um specifically compare models
um uh you know in search
um
automated retraining or you know
pipeline
so basically you have a Model A previous
model so uh and then you trim the new
one and you want to just can I evaluate
and say you know which of these are
better like in on average and should I
what should I go ahead
and so I want to do this in the in a
statistical Manner and not just test on
one data set or like you know make one
point you know estimate Point
calculation and say this accuracy is
like 10 or five percent better than this
so we're gonna go with this uh and so
that's what motivated this this part of
the discussion and I'm just gonna go
over some techniques that I use for this
this kind of analysis and
um show results or some experience that
I want to kind of test
um this on a test set of data and you
know to actually facilitate discussion
and then conclude with um looking at
other considerations other things we
look at Beyond this kind of validation
for why use case health insurance
um industry
so a very common thing that people use
in situations like this is of course
they're very very popular details so you
have a bunch of other
um you know differences in accurations
between two models
um you you can take make a difference of
them and then you know you can set up a
t-test which you know you can set up
your hypothesis but now the the main
difference between them is kind of
greater than zero or as it's not the
same as zero and then you can go ahead
and do your analysis and
um come to a conclusion accept of reject
the hypothesis the bigger model based on
that and go ahead
um not only this is kind of like
implemented in the context of like you
know CVS or cross validation where you
kind of like you know have different
force of data and kind of
um do this analysis on the different
faults and results that metrics that
come from the different forms of data
um what happens is that because you know
there's a bunch of overlap with this
data uh when you calculate the variance
that goes into the denominator of this
you know the statistics that I showed on
right you have like you know correlation
effects that kind of like introduce
super first type one errors that you
don't want to kind of like see happen
and so because of this you know there
have been no adaptations of this model
to kind of like handle some of this and
that's some of the matters I'm going to
talk about
um here today
one of them is the um the correlated
t-test we just are put together by this
one by Nadia and Benjo
um so basically I mean I have this here
just for to kind of point out what's the
difference between this and the previous
um method that I looked at
but basically you introduce this
heuristic kind of like an approximation
for a correlation which
um
is dependent on the number of samples
you have in your test setting it when
you said and then you use that um to
kind of like modify that denominator to
kind of like handle that kind of
um correlation problem and then you have
the same at the end of the day you have
a similar statistic that follows the
same distribution and then you can you
know you can follow the entire
missionary of the work and accept the
rejected hypothesis based on the outcome
of that
um analysis
another method that I saw in the
literature when I was looking at this
and I have
um I forget I forgot to mention earlier
but I have a references in the bottom so
if you want to look this up later and
look at the details on how these things
were and I don't you can do that and and
I think this this video is available for
look at that later on
but basically there's this other test
that was put together by Thomas Dietrich
which is called the five
um two CV pair test which um has this
interest in algorithm where it takes
around five-fold of a situation where
that's the data sets places into test
agar Trends algorithm a for instance on
uh one of them and then test on the
other and then Trends on the other and
test on the other fold and does that for
algorithm B so you have this kind of
like four quantities that is used to
calculate
um a kind of modified variance on the
top of the right hand side and then that
goes into the T statistics this is
bottom uh and in the analysis they they
were able to like show that you know the
statistic that when that's shown there
um if if not follows a a student
distribution with five degrees of
freedom and then once that is
established and you do this you can
again go ahead and you know do
everything or make it a decision about
your
Things based on businesses
um so on this method and a few others
that I looked at uh were all kind of
like you know uh frequencies type of
analysis we know rejecting the new lot
but this is based on like a p-value
um and and jokes of significance there's
a problem with that because I know
sometimes that can be a little arbitrary
and like you know people have been a lot
of you know
um concern about that uh more recently
so I decided uh um in addition you know
you have this uh original problem with
you know when you apply this in the
context of a CV of results you have
um correlations kind of spurious
correlations that you want to handle in
a kind of an ad hoc manner so because of
that I mean you know there have been
more some work recently in the you know
the application of Bayesian methods to
kind of compare models in this kind of
setting
and so I
introduced the patient correlated
theaters that was um and I'm following
the treatment in the in the reference
below uh unlike the the key thing about
the way they went about this is that
they model the kind of vector of
differences uh by of course the mean
you're trying to kind of like model
uh and at some of that Main and they're
kind of motivated
um normal noise with means zero uh uh
and and so and the covariance Matrix
that's that's the off sorry diagonal
elements represent um the variance and
then the off diagonals kind of like tie
into
um the correlation we were talking about
so if you apply this apply this method
in the
um
now to see this set and we we talked
about earlier it's kind of natural
because it covers um on the things that
you want that you're concerned about
um
being a vision kind of like um analysis
test you what you end up with is the
probability distribution of the
posterior which is something you can
query to make uh and and the outcomes
that is very straightforward their
probability so you can say this is the
probability that this model behaves in a
certain way which is very different from
the setting of uh you know hypothesis
test where you just accept or rejected
hypothesis based on some arbitrary or
p-value and like you know confidence in
our
um something else that I'm going to talk
about a bit more in the next slide as
well is this
um in in this kind of treatment they
introduce this kind of like concept of
um something called the region of
practical significance which is kind of
a nice way to kind of decide how
models are close enough for you to say
that they are practically the same and
I'm going to talk about that a little
later with some visual aids they're
going to make things a bit um player
and so as I have um kind of mentioned
previously as well um you you end up
with a posterior distribution in this
case in the treatment they did it
actually turns out to be a student
distribution which is something we we
know I mean we are combusted with
Invasion analysis or like in you know in
statistics
um and and this distribution describes
the distribution of the difference in
accuracies for example in this case and
in the particular case we are looking at
right now and so uh if you look at the
figure on the right in that density plus
you see these two Orange Lines and
that's kind of like the origin around
you know one percent around zero sorry
one percent around zero in the
difference in accuracies which is kind
of like you know a number you can decide
beforehand and say you know
um
result that within one percent I
consider those to be equivalent and so
you can Define that and then obtain the
probability that your model
um is actually the same based on that
and that's just given by the density
that is enclosed in that term in that in
the you know between those horizontal
lines over there and then you know to
the right and to the left um if you do
it kind of an integral over the other
information over that gives you the
probability that a maybe a Model A in
this case one case is no has such a
probability of being a better model and
vice versa but that b is about has this
certain probability of being the better
model so it's a bit more straightforward
interpretation of kind of like this
analysis uh you know going forward
and so I am just gonna give the drift
kind of a view of um the experiment that
I run uh the models we're looking at as
one have already intermediate earlier
like Risk classification models that we
use in our the business in life
insurance and you know on the writing in
general I'm using an accuracy metric
here but of course the metric could be
different this is just kind of historic
there's a legacy of the particular
obligation uh with around seven thousand
seventy thousand instances of data
looked at good kind of upgrading or
updating skills
um there's still a lot is going on in
this level but I'm going to work through
it and hopefully it's going to make a
bit more sense as we uh we progress but
I just want to say um before going
forward the first three rules kind of
show uh is kind of like an upgradance
game where
you know I'm comparing the results of
applying of a random service and a
classifier the logistic regression
classifier and it uh bottom three rules
I random version like a GBM classifier
and I'm just going to go over each of
the columns I can explain what they mean
so Model A of course means that this is
this is the model that was used in this
particular test
same will model B
um the next column is what the you know
the analysis decides is the best model
out of this uh what particular test or
analysis that I actually implemented in
this case
um The Nest column for the average score
is what the average accuracy for um
Model A was in the in the test and the
same thing for model B
the next one is and what is the region
what is used and what percentage
within the accuracy was used as the
so-called region of you know practical
equivalence in this experiment
um this of course only applies to the
Bayesian test because that is the early
situation where it applies
um props a is kind of like short for
probability
but basically that is the probability
that model A is the better model
um
props row means the probability that you
know D not both models are kind of
equivalent
B is probably the B is the better model
and P value is just another P value from
the frequences analysis
um
so as I mentioned as uh let me go back
one step as you can see like in the
logistic regression case
random first it's very clear if you look
at the accuracy that there's some
separation between both two plus plus
models and so all the test types are
able to like really kind of like figure
this out and like you know say that
no the random for us is the better model
here in the case of the light GBM the
last three rows it's a bit more
confusing and it's two percent model
fail here and um this is this is an
example from a series of no of course
like experiment that I run and it's a
very typical thing and that's which is
why I want to kind of highlight it
um that that seems to happen a lot
um and you can see why the light GBM uh
one kind of fails here from the results
you get from The Invasion analysts uh if
you look at the the orange vertical
lines again you'll see that close to 60
of the density is within Europe and so
um just around 40 or so uh probability
that um
the light GBM model is actually better
so in this case you know the the uh the
version model gives you some more
information on like to help you like
make this decision to say maybe this
model is a quick relent while in the
other cases you could just be you know
either pass or fail you know or of the
hypothesis in this case it just passes
because yeah the light GBM does a little
bit is amazing better
but no you don't have that contact that
you get from Foundation
and this is in in the logistic
regression case which is right now first
you can see why you know it's very
smooth on all methods get it right
because most of the density you know the
probability is very much outside here
and it's easier to see that uh with the
Bayesian analysis
I also show the result of kind of like
an upgrade uh
um update system where you know
um similar model classes applied on an
update in the data set and the same kind
of like scenario from before plays out
here uh when these are gonna
illustrative examples as well but you
can see that um the Asian test is able
to kind of like sell soft things a
little bit better and be able to say
that it models are identical more or
less
uh and then you can see again why that
is the case here the entire density is
within rope so the probability that you
know
um you know their equivalent is pretty
much one
and so the takeaways from this uh
analysis is that you know overall you
know the patient applications that I
looked at here I mean both Metals kind
of work depending on the setting but um
uh division methods provide more
information for you to make decisions uh
and you can you know set up automatic
decisions where you can say you know the
probability of you know model ABM beta
is greater than 70 or also 90 or 95
statistically you know kind of like
analogous to what you say you know in uh
yeah Alpha in in
frequencies analysis then you know what
it is better and then you know you can
push that down in the pipeline and then
you know after for that review of course
if this offer that steps down as we we
have then you can promote the model into
the model that's kind of like you know
you serve or if uh you know if
probability of rope is you know greater
than 90 then
you know you can't do that however it
takes a bit longer to kind of train
compared to uh the fragmented models of
course but in our application in my use
case
um this works so just the very last
slide before I conclude is kind of like
tie things back together is that I
haven't done all this kind of validation
and in our set and we then do a bit to
consider a few more things like you know
we check for bias metrics and fairness
because we want to be Equitable in the
access to you know insurance and things
like that we have gov governmental kind
of regulations to kind of consider as
well so we take those in different
situation and look at the risk
assessment how this model you know what
kind of exposure it gives though you
know we will get out of using this kind
of models
so overall that's gonna like tears up
all the concentration we look at for a
kind of application like this and um
hopefully we have a few moments for some
questions from you guys
thank you
enough any questions any questions
um so so there are two things right you
know so you can run both models and
share you can run the new model on a
shadow mode or you can run in an AV
fashion or either so it's a a model so
one is active and the both models are
active but one is getting in 20 of the
the traffic and Etc so in that sense you
have to get the errors and also have to
figure out like where to stop that
tracking right do you have a you know
just want to get your thoughts on you
know how do you track and how do you
also get the errors for they are
consistent they're significantly you
know they're statistically significant
that's a good point uh so I think I can
answer one part of your question where
you're talking about different types of
deployments uh there's like you talked
about like an A B tested situation where
you're testing two different models
right I think we could call it a canary
situation where you're directing some
traffic to one model and everything some
traffic to the model Arcus is kind of
are somewhat complicated in the sense
where we can't have two models from the
same time because we have to be uh we
have to have like
more regulatory control over what we're
sending it so like if like for example
two models out there one produces one
risk class per person and another person
is produced a different risk class the
other person will produce a different
risk class and that's like offers opens
us to lots of class action losses I
guess
so there's like so you have to be very
very restrictive in the types of models
that you're pushing out and so online uh
testing essentially is very kind of
complicated for us what we do is we do
lots of offline stuff so evaluating
metrics or uh let's say uh evaluating
stuff that you essentially do in your
experimentation let's say the accuracy
the predictions all that stuff and
seeing the quality of data repeating
that in production and then also some of
those statistical tests
make sense
any other questions
just a quick question actually uh
yeah I just wanted to to know if you
were able to use the uncertainty that
get out of the Bayesian framework uh for
for any uh modeling decisions like
how can you use the the uncertainty to
make like the modeling decisions out of
framework for your elaborate on multiple
decisions no I'm getting different data
or changing the the modeling so are you
using that uncertainty for any any any
other mode
yeah
um not right now but I can see how that
can be used or you can for example like
for
um if you if you look at some of the
graphs I showed I mean
the uncertainty if you look at the width
of the distribution it kind of gives you
like kind of notion of how how second it
is around certain um situation so uh I
can see that being used
but at the moment no
all right
that's a good idea
any other questions
thank you for the talk and and giving an
interesting like framework for for doing
this
um I have a question about uh you know
deciding on on how big of an effect size
is Meaningful
um
how do you go about deciding what that
effect size is and then even if you've
decided in effect size how is the
Bayesian approach different from
hypothesis testing but just having your
hypothesis be that that the that the
means are not equal that they're just
less than or equal to you know one or
you know 0.1 or whatever
yeah
um
I mean in fact there's something you
decide on a case like is basically based
based on your application
um in terms of
I mean what you're trying to do I mean
at least what I was modeling in the um
in the applications and the examples I
was showing is that you know that the
the main the differences the main
differences is different from zeros and
and certainly you can you can say it's
different from 0.1 or 0. something like
that uh but then
again it's
it's
a bit more arbitrary
um and because again what at the end of
the day there are two things
um one you chose a certain number and
then you go with that
um
but at the end of the day you still have
some of the problems that that um that
that were mentioned around for example
hacker look at these samples and that's
things that are not done so handled and
so overall you still have a higher value
of type 1 errors that arise in this in
this case compared to like when you use
a kind of like version and specify
something like
um a rope
um I mean the the good thing about the
ropes in the patient situation is that
now you can be very principled about
what that group is and you can say no
for most of our models in this model
class you know one percent is that five
percent is good and and that is fine but
in other case again you just reject uh
reduce the hypothesis but it doesn't it
doesn't really say something about why
you should accept
um
uh something else as well so I think the
same kind of scenario the same kind of
problems still arise even if you you
know you move things a little bit
differently on the
practice this way
okay thank you so much guys uh so we'll
be moving on to uh so let's give them a
hierarchy
[Applause]